voilà l'idée c'est que en fait je donne
des titres de vos chansons et le défi
c'est qu' il dit qu'il est capable de
tout chanter on va voir s'il est capable
véritablement alors que les accepter une
des filles vous voulez j'enlève
l'oreillette
ah bah oui bah évidemment d'accord
est-ce qu'on peut ramener une autre
orientation votre gentil à vous devez
chanter comme ça quand c'est parti et
après ça vous pour être jugé on commence
par comme ils disent j'habite seul avec
maman ou dans un très vieil appartement
russe à rabat
j'ai pour me tenir compagnie une tortue
et de cannabis et plus joyeux que
l'original mais c'est bien sûr la mama
et sont venus ils sont tous là
dès qu'ils ont entendu ce cri elle va
mourir à duda
[Musique]
hier encore j'avais de râteaux je
caressais le tour est joué de la vie
quand on joue de l'amour et je vivais là
devis sans compter sur les jours qui
fuyait dans le temps et j'ai relevé j'ai
alors
emmenez moi
[Applaudissements]
ce
d'ailleurs la dernière
on va bloquer quoi les haies les fourmis
formi formi formidable kanak c'est lui
sert ici de l'anglais je suis une
catastrophe
bah je vous le dis à moi franchement je
peux vous faire quelques petites
critiques
j'apprends beaucoup venons de vous
vraiment ça me touche toujours là dans
la maman je vous ai trouvé trop gay et
donc comme ils disent pas assez donc là
bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]